Remember years ago, the guy who ran the military, Secretary of Defense Donald Rumsfeld, said, kind of famously, there are the things we know, the things we don't know, and there are the things that we don't even know we don't know. That last kind of spooky category he called the unknown unknowns.
多年前，掌管军方的国防部长唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德曾说了一句很有名的话：有些事是我们知道的，有些事是我们不知道的，还有些事是我们连自己不知道什么都不知道的。他把最后那种有点诡异的类别称为“未知的未知”。
And I guess maybe talking about known unknowns and unknown unknowns might have been appropriate for the thing he was talking about, which was Iraq and weapons of mass destruction. But who knew that someday it was going to be a good way to describe the chaos swirling this year around two of which should be the most pedestrian, predictable things the government does-- counting votes in an election and starting the school year.
我想，谈论已知的未知和未知的未知，或许适用于他当时讨论的问题，也就是伊拉克和大规模杀伤性武器。但谁能想到，有一天这会成为描述今年围绕两件本该是政府最简单、最可预测的事情所产生的混乱的绝佳方式——选举计票和开学。
OK, let's save the election for another day. Can we talk right now about the demolition derby multi-car pileup of known unknowns and unknown unknowns that is the opening of this school year? Matt teaches at a big high school in the suburbs of South Carolina. And all summer he's been doing what parents and teachers everywhere have been doing this year, wondering if there's going to be in-person instruction this fall and watching state and local officials give out information that seemed incomplete, and contradictory, and confusing.
好吧，选举的事改天再说。我们现在能聊聊今年开学时那场关于已知未知和未知未知的多车连环相撞事故吗？马特在南卡罗来纳州郊区的一所大型高中教书。整个夏天，他一直在做全天下的家长和老师今年都在做的事：想知道今年秋天是否会有线下授课，并看着州和地方官员发布那些看起来既不完整、又自相矛盾、还让人困惑的信息。
And it was sort of like hot potato of responsibility too. It was like everybody was kind of passing, you know, like, when you hear from your district, when you hear from the state superintendent, when we hear from our gov-- you know.
而且这还有点像责任推卸的游戏。就好像每个人都在推诿，你知道的，当你从学区、州督学或者我们的州长那里听到消息时……你懂的。
Oh, they're all saying somebody else is going to set the course, and then you'll know.
哦，他们都在说别人会制定方针，然后你就会知道了。
Yeah, it felt very deflective.
是的，感觉非常像是在推卸责任。
By August, when they got to the first day, the teachers reported back to school-- no kids there yet, just teachers. Matt says things still seemed very unclear.
到了八月，开学第一天，老师们回到学校——学生还没到，只有老师。马特说事情依然很不清楚。
Thinking surely when we get in the building, we're going to get the answers. The answer is in the building where my bosses are, they're going to know. And over the course of the week, sort of having the veil lifted and realizing my bosses don't know anything more than I do about the start of school-- like, my principal and I know the exact same amount of information.
本以为等我们到了学校，肯定能得到答案。答案应该在学校里，就在我的上司那里，他们肯定会知道的。但在这一周的时间里，面纱逐渐揭开，我意识到我的上司对开学的事了解得并不比我多——比如，我和我的校长知道的信息完全一样多。
At that point, teachers had received an email with a tentative plan, but the emphasis was very much on "tentative." His principal noted, quote, "Things change daily." The plan was called the A/B plan, and it was the hybrid plan that lots of schools are doing.
那时，老师们收到了一封附有初步计划的电子邮件，但重点非常强调了“初步”二字。他的校长指出，引用原话，“情况每天都在变”。该计划被称为A/B计划，是许多学校正在采用的混合模式。
Students will be divided into two groups, A and B. Half would come to school for two days while the other half would stay home and join online using Zoom, then they'd switch. But if you want to see a high school spinning through the maelstrom of known unknowns and unknown unknowns, OK, here is what happened that first day the teachers came back.
学生将被分为A组和B组。一半学生来学校待两天，另一半在家通过Zoom在线参加，然后他们轮换。但如果你想看看一所高中在已知未知和未知未知的漩涡中挣扎，好吧，这就是老师们回来的第一天发生的事情。
The first meeting that I go to is at 10:00. And it's a department meeting, so we have just 15 people spread out.
我参加的第一个会议是在10点。那是部门会议，所以我们只有15个人散开坐着。
And you all are sitting there socially distanced from each other, wearing masks.
你们都保持社交距离坐着，戴着口罩。
Yep. There's a good atmosphere in the room. All things considered, we're happy to be there and happy to see each other-- a very glass half full, whatever may come sort of vibe in the room. And our department head, who's a teacher, has written up these two plans on the board-- the A day, B day sort of hybrid plan and then an all-virtual start.
是的。房间里的氛围不错。总的来说，我们很高兴能在那里，也很高兴见到彼此——房间里有一种苦中作乐、无论发生什么都泰然处之的氛围。我们的部门主管，他也是一位老师，在黑板上写下了两个计划——A天/B天的混合计划，以及全面网课的方案。
Virtual start-- no students in the building, you're teaching everybody online.
全面网课——学校里没有学生，你要在网上教所有人。
Correct.
没错。
Got it.
明白了。
Yeah. We get a little into this meeting, and we have an administrator-- one of our assistant principals is in the room, and he's been mostly quiet. But when we get to a conversation about how we get back into teaching, he sort of pipes in, and he says, hang on. And he's like, the A day, B day plan is out. Apparently they had received word from the district that our school needed to cancel that plan. So, all right, everybody, first change, curve ball coming at 11:00 AM. Change of plans-- let's plan on all virtual.
是的。会议进行了一会儿，我们的一位行政人员——我们的一位副校长在房间里，他大部分时间都很安静。但当我们开始讨论如何回归教学时，他插了一句，他说，等一下。他说，A天/B天计划取消了。显然，他们收到了学区的通知，说我们学校需要取消该计划。好吧，各位，第一次变动，上午11点迎来了变化球。计划变更——准备全面网课。
So to summarize, 10 o'clock it's A/B. 11 o'clock it's all virtual. Or anyway, that's how Matt took it. His department chair told us he had no idea what would happen.
所以总结一下，10点是A/B计划。11点变成全面网课了。总之，马特是这么理解的。他的系主任告诉我们，他根本不知道会发生什么。
So meeting ends. Then around 2:00 in the afternoon, word sort of spreads that there's this bomb drop of an announcement. And that administrator who had been in our meeting caught my colleague in the hall, and he was kind of flustered. And he said, plans are changing again. We just got word from the district. So it's just like, wait for the staff meeting. Let's see what happens.
会议结束了。下午2点左右，有消息传出，有一条重磅公告。我们会议上的那位行政人员在走廊里拦住了我的同事，他看起来很慌乱。他说，计划又变了。我们刚收到学区的通知。所以就像是，等全体教职工会议吧。看看会发生什么。
The staff meeting is the big welcome to the new school year all staff meeting for the whole faculty. And it starts at 3 o'clock.
全体教职工会议是为全校教职工举办的盛大开学欢迎会。会议在3点开始。
About 250 teachers are on this Zoom call. We're all in our own rooms.
大约250名老师参加了这个Zoom通话。我们都在自己的房间里。
You're all in the building, but you're in your own rooms--
你们都在学校里，但都在各自的房间里——
Yes.
是的。
--on Zoom.
——在Zoom上开会。
Yeah. And then like nothing happens at this meeting. The whole meeting is trivial information. They introduce new faculty members. They share positive news from teachers' summers, like new babies or engagements. They talk about our SAT scores from last year, all the things that we hear annually.
是的。然后这次会议上什么都没发生。整个会议都是些琐碎的信息。他们介绍了新教员。分享了老师们暑期的喜讯，比如新生儿或订婚。他们谈论了我们去年的SAT成绩，所有我们每年都会听到的那些事。
When they finally do talk about the restart plan, he says it's a lot of we can do it positivity, but no concrete details about whether they'd be going all virtual or what the plan was going to be.
当他们最终谈到重启计划时，他说了很多“我们能做到”的积极话语，但对于是否会全面网课，或者具体计划是什么，没有任何实质性的细节。
So the meeting ends, and we're all sort of sitting there thinking like, what was it? And my colleague and I are determined to figure this out. So it's 4:00 now. We're like, we're going to go down to the administrators' offices and just see what we can see.
会议结束了，我们都坐在那里想，刚才说了什么？我和同事决定弄清楚这件事。现在已经是4点了。我们心想，我们要去行政办公室看看到底能发现什么。
And we go to one of the administrator's offices, and there are two other assistant principals in there. It's pretty jammed. And it's sort of like the situation room in any White House action drama. There's papers all over the table, and everybody's on their computer. And even for as few people are in the room, they're sort of talking past each other, and there are multiple conversations going on.
我们走到其中一个行政办公室，里面还有另外两位副校长。挤得满满当当。简直就像任何白宫动作片里的作战室。桌上全是文件，每个人都在用电脑。即使房间里没几个人，他们也在互相插话，同时进行着好几场对话。
And my friend and I kind of got that vibe of like, we're just going to stand at the door. We're not even going to come in, wade into the water. But what we find out is that in the afternoon, the district apparently came back to the schools and was like, OK, new plan. You need students in the building on the first day of school, five days a week, at 25% capacity. That's all we're giving you. Figure it out.
我和朋友感受到那种氛围，就觉得，我们就在门口站着吧。甚至不去掺和。但我们发现，当天下午，学区显然又回到了学校，说，好吧，新计划。第一天就需要学生在校，每周五天，25%的容量。这是我们能给你们的全部。自己搞定吧。
What?
什么？
And so what we see on the table are all these rosters of students and scheduling. And so there's some logistical nightmare.
所以我们在桌上看到了这些学生名单和排课表。真是物流噩梦。
The logistical nightmare is because South Carolina mandates that every parent should have the option to send their kid to school for in-person instruction if they want or keep them at home for virtual learning if that's what they want, which is the kind of trying to please everybody solution that in practice is just enormously difficult to execute.
物流噩梦是因为南卡罗来纳州规定，每位家长都应该有选择权，如果愿意，可以将孩子送到学校接受线下指导，或者如果愿意，让他们留在家中进行在线学习。这种试图取悦所有人的解决方案，在实践中执行起来极其困难。
It means that there have to be some students in school five days a week. But, of course, there's only so much space in the school for students with proper social distancing. So how do you figure out who gets to attend and who does not get to attend, and what happens when you cannot give every family what it wants?
这意味着必须有一些学生每周五天在学校上课。但当然，学校里能容纳保持适当社交距离的学生空间有限。那么你如何确定谁能上学，谁不能上学？当你无法满足每个家庭的需求时该怎么办？
Meanwhile in the classrooms, as South Carolina heads towards the first day of classes September 8, teachers have to figure out how to do something that they did not do last spring when schools went on quarantine. They had to figure out, how do you teach a class that is partly at home and partly in the room with you?
与此同时，在教室里，随着南卡罗来纳州向9月8日开学第一天迈进，老师们必须弄清楚如何做一些他们在去年春天学校隔离时没有做过的事情。他们不得不弄清楚，如何教一个既有学生在家、又有学生在教室里的班级？
Which is a particularly-- it's particularly funny to think for choir, it's a very difficult subject to teach virtually.
这特别……想到合唱课就觉得特别好笑，这是一种很难在线上教授的科目。
Oh, Matt, he's a choir teacher.
哦，马特，他是一位合唱老师。
Trying to sing in a Zoom with other people is just a nightmare, because you can't even-- if you say let's clap at the same time, you'll hear a bunch of different claps because everybody's--
试图通过Zoom和别人一起唱歌简直是噩梦，因为你甚至不能——如果你说我们同时拍手，你会听到一堆不同的拍手声，因为每个人都……
Oh, of course. There's a little delay, and that delay makes it impossible to sing together.
哦，当然。有一点延迟，而那个延迟使得一起唱歌变得不可能。
Yeah, not to mention that usually the software is built to identify who is speaking and amplify their voice, and silence other people.
是的，更不用说软件通常被设定为识别谁在说话并放大他们的声音，同时让其他人静音。
So the only way to sing together is with everybody on mute, and what kind of rehearsal is that? And the one fourth of the class that's going to be in the room with him, they can't sing together in the room because singing in a chorus can be a super spreader event for the virus. Remember that choir near Seattle at the beginning of the pandemic where 52 people got sick? Even with masks it's not safe, which means singing together is the one thing you cannot do in chorus.
所以一起唱歌的唯一方法就是让所有人静音，那算哪门子排练？而班里那四分之一在教室里的学生，他们也不能在教室里一起唱歌，因为合唱中的歌唱可能是病毒的超级传播事件。还记得疫情初期西雅图附近的那个合唱团吗？52个人生病了。即使戴着口罩也不安全，这意味着在一起唱歌是合唱课中你唯一不能做的事情。
Matt's classes are 90 minutes long, and right now he figures he'll teach the kids on Zoom and the kids in the classroom together for half an hour at the beginning of it, lecture style, give out singing assignments to do at home--
马特的课时长90分钟，目前他打算在课开始时，通过Zoom同时教那些孩子和在教室里的孩子半小时，采用讲课风格，布置在家进行的歌唱任务——
And then at the 30-minute mark or something, I would probably dismiss those Zoom students, say, like, OK, you've got your assignments. I'll see you soon-- take the students that are in the room somewhere outside where we can be spaced out and actually practice singing with them.
然后在30分钟左右，我可能会让那些Zoom学生下课，说，好的，你们有作业了。待会儿见——带教室里的学生去外面某个地方，我们可以保持距离，真正和他们一起练习唱歌。
Weather permitting.
如果天气允许的话。
Yeah. We're going to have to just MacGyver the whole semester basically.
是的。基本上我们整个学期都得像马盖先那样去凑合。
So you're re-engineering every part of your job? Like, every single part of it?
所以你在重新设计工作的每一个部分？就像每一个部分？
Exactly.
完全正确。
Other teachers have said this to me too, that virtual teaching is making them rethink and re-engineer the most basic things they do in their jobs to get through to kids. A second grade teacher in Chicago told me that she was still struggling to figure out how she was going to hold the attention of a bunch of seven-year-olds over video for the mandated three hours a day of live, real-time instruction.
其他老师也对我这么说过，虚拟教学让他们反思并重新设计工作中完成教学所需的最基本的事情。芝加哥的一位二年级老师告诉我，她仍在努力寻找如何通过视频吸引一群七岁孩子注意力的方法，因为每天有强制性的三小时现场实时教学。
She was like, I don't even know if developmentally, that's even possible for them to focus on the screen for that long. Not to mention, what activities was she going to give these little kids to do on their own, unsupervised by her, for the hours they would not be on video with her? She was spending weeks before school started, every day on her own time, unpaid to figure this out.
她说，我甚至不知道从发育角度看，他们是否能在屏幕前专注那么久。更不用说，她该给这些小孩子什么活动，让他们在没有她监督的情况下，在她不通过视频授课的那些时间里自己去做？在学校开学前的几周，她每天都利用自己的私人时间，无薪地去研究这些。
It's been a few days since I've recorded that conversation with Matt. And since then, his high school surveyed the teachers and realized that so many of them wanted to stay home and teach from home that there's no way they could actually have 25% of the students come back for in-person instruction. Right now it seems like they're only going to have enough instructors for fewer than 10% of the students. But administrators are still figuring it out.
距离我录制和马特的谈话已经过去几天了。从那以后，他的高中对老师们进行了调查，发现很多人希望留在家中远程教学，以至于他们根本不可能实现25%的学生返校线下授课。目前看来，他们拥有的老师可能只够不足10%的学生线下上课。但行政人员们仍在设法解决。
And of course, who knows how everything is going to unfold in September when kids actually arrive. Will anybody get COVID? Will things be fine? Matt knows some teachers in states where school has already started.
当然，谁知道9月份孩子们真正到达时会发生什么呢？会有人感染新冠吗？一切会好吗？马特认识一些学校已经开学的州的老师。
What it feels like right now is going cliff jumping with your friends. And our friends next to us are Georgia and Alabama. And we're like, 1, 2, 3-- and we're like, I'll see you in four weeks, as they're jumping off. Because we want to see what happens to the other districts. I'm starting to see-- I have friends in Louisiana that are teaching entirely virtually. I have friends in Georgia and Alabama that are posting their Instagram stories of Plexiglas in front of their desk, and like, here we go.
现在的感觉就像和朋友一起去悬崖跳水。我们旁边的朋友是乔治亚州和阿拉巴马州。我们说，1，2，3——就像在说，跳吧，四周后再见。因为我们想看看其他学区发生了什么。我开始看到……我在路易斯安那州的朋友正在进行全线上教学。我在乔治亚州和阿拉巴马州的朋友在Ins上发布照片，桌前放着有机玻璃挡板，像是说，我们要开始了。
Are you in that weird situation where you actually don't know what's going to happen and you're kind of worried, but you have to deal with parents and students? And with them, do you let them know your apprehensions? Or do you just keep like a big smiley face, and, like, it's going to be great? Do you feel like you're lying?
你是否处于那种奇怪的境地，你实际上不知道会发生什么，你有点担心，但你必须应付家长和学生？对他们，你会表达你的忧虑吗？还是你会一直保持大大的笑脸，好像一切都会很棒？你觉得你在撒谎吗？
[LAUGHS] Yeah, it sort of feels-- it feels a little contorted. Like, I have teachers that are posting first day of school pictures as always. And they sound bright and cheery. And it's like, can't wait to see my students, despite the challenges. Really excited to show them a great new year.
[笑] 是的，感觉确实有点扭曲。就像我有些老师同事像往常一样发布开学第一天的照片。他们听起来明亮又欢快。就像是，迫不及待想见到我的学生，尽管有困难。真的很高兴向他们展示一个伟大的新学年。
But underneath the surface, these teachers are my friends, and I know these teachers are terrified. And it feels twisted this year because we really don't know what our safety looks like and what our students' safety looks like, but you still have to be the boss in front of the class and be like-- [CLAPS] --what's up, y'all? So excited you're here. Let's go. I am going to put my best foot forward because I can't wait to teach kids, and I love doing that, but I'm scared [BLEEP] -less about what the year looks like.
但在表面之下，这些老师是我的朋友，我知道这些老师很害怕。今年感觉很扭曲，因为我们真的不知道我们的安全状况如何，也不知道我们学生的安全状况如何，但你依然得在课堂上当老板，表现得像——[拍手]——怎么了，各位？很高兴你们在这里。我们开始吧。我会全力以赴，因为我迫不及待想教孩子们，我热爱这份工作，但我吓得要死，不知道今年会是什么样子。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. Today on our program, teachers, students, parents launch themselves into a school year that is beginning like none that any of us have ever experienced. Since the spring, everybody has been anticipating the school opening like this-- I don't know-- this asteroid that we've all been watching head towards Earth, floating towards us, tumbling towards us in space in slow motion.
这里是来自WBEZ芝加哥的《美国生活》。今天我们的节目主题是，老师、学生、家长投身于一个我们任何人都从未经历过的开学季。从春天开始，每个人就一直像这样期待着开学——我不知道——就像那颗我们都看着它冲向地球的小行星，漂浮在我们身边，在太空中缓慢地向我们翻滚而来。
And now it is finally hitting, and we are finding out if it is just as bad as we thought it was going to be or way better than we hoped. We have stories from around the country of it going badly and, I'm glad to tell you, and some places going surprisingly well, at least for now anyway. Stay with us.
现在它终于撞击了，我们正在发现它是否像我们想象的那样糟糕，或者比我们希望的要好得多。我们有来自全国各地的故事，有的进展糟糕，也有的，我很荣幸地告诉大家，至少目前为止进展得出奇地好。请留在这里。
Act One, Masked Crusaders. So right before school started in Utah this month, our producer Miki Meek caught up with two high school teachers. Clark is 33. Bayley's 26. They're married, and we agreed not to use their last names. They joke that their pillow talk is reviewing each other's lessons for the next day.
第一幕，戴口罩的十字军。在本月犹他州开学前夕，我们的制作人米基·米克采访了两位高中老师。克拉克33岁，贝莉26岁。他们是夫妻，我们同意不使用他们的姓氏。他们开玩笑说，他们的枕边话就是互相检查第二天的课程。
Clark teaches art and photography. This year's his sixth year as a teacher. Bayley's a newbie, about to have her own classroom for the very first time, teaching sophomore English. The two of them teach at different public high schools in Utah County, south of Salt Lake City. And they found themselves thrown into this really heated and ugly fight in the county right before schools open back up. Here's Miki.
克拉克教艺术和摄影。今年是他教书的第六年。贝莉是个新手，即将第一次拥有自己的教室，教十年级英语。他们两人在盐湖城以南的犹他县不同的公立高中任教。在学校开学前，他们发现自己被卷入了这个县一场非常激烈且丑陋的争斗中。这里是米基。
Clark and Bayley are still these fresh-faced, enthusiastic teachers, but they spent the summer stressing about their schools reopening because COVID cases had started surging in Utah. Both of them would have classes with as many as 40 students in them. Their classrooms are too small to space desks six feet apart. And the windows, they don't open.
克拉克和贝莉仍然是这些面孔清新、热情洋溢的老师，但整个夏天他们都在为学校重新开放而感到压力，因为犹他州的新冠病例开始激增。他们两人都有班级学生人数高达40人。他们的教室太小，无法让课桌保持六英尺的间距。而且窗户是打不开的。
Governor Gary Herbert issued a mask mandate for all K through 12 schools, which made them feel a little better, until a county commissioner, a guy named Bill Lee, he started lobbying against it. He thought it should be up to parents whether their kids wear a mask. He called it a, quote, "compassionate exemption."
州长加里·赫伯特对所有幼儿园到12年级的学校发布了口罩强制令，这让他们感觉好了一些，直到一位名叫比尔·李的县专员开始游说反对它。他认为是否戴口罩应该由家长决定。他称之为“富有同情心的豁免”。
To try to drum up support, he invited parents to the commission's next meeting. Suddenly you were either pro-mask or anti-mask. Clark and Bayley decided to go in support of masks.
为了争取支持，他邀请家长参加委员会的下一次会议。突然间，你不是支持口罩派就是反对口罩派。克拉克和贝莉决定去支持口罩。
But going into it I was like, is anyone really going to be there? Like, who's going to go to protest masks? I just thought, are there going to be 10 people there? I have no idea.
但在去之前我心想，真的会有人去吗？谁会去抗议口罩？我只是想，会有10个人吗？我完全不知道。
There were actually around 100 people there. The meeting was held at the county building in Provo. And when Clark and Bayley got there, they saw mostly moms gathered outside, some with kids. Hardly anyone was wearing a mask. But one family who was wearing masks stopped Bayley.
实际上有大约100人在那里。会议在普罗沃的县政府大楼举行。当克拉克和贝莉到那里时，他们看到外面聚集的大多是妈妈，有些人还带着孩子。几乎没有人戴口罩。但有一个戴口罩的家庭拦住了贝莉。
They were like, you should go in, because there's like no one really in support of masks. And so I was like, OK, I'm going in. And I just kind of ran in the building.
他们说，你应该进去，因为真的没什么人支持戴口罩。所以我心想，好的，我要进去。我就跑进了大楼。
It was packed. There were chairs set up with tape across them for social distancing, but that didn't work so well.
里面挤满了人。椅子上贴着胶带用于社交距离，但这根本没起作用。
People were just peeling off the tape and sitting down. And people were just riled up. You could feel this energy that was really intense.
人们只是撕掉胶带坐了下来。人们情绪激动。你能感觉到那种能量非常强烈。
And just wearing a mask in that space put a target on your head immediately.
而且在那个空间里戴着口罩，会立刻让你成为众矢之的。
Yeah.
是的。
The room was hot and crowded, and a bunch of people without masks were fanning their faces.
房间里又热又挤，一群没戴口罩的人在扇风。
And we're good to go. All right.
好了，准备开始了。
That's a county commissioner named Tanner Ainge. He was not happy about this meeting.
那是县专员坦纳·艾恩奇。他对这次会议感到不高兴。
Hello, everyone. This is going to be brief, I think. This is the exact opposite of what we need to be doing. We are supposed to be physically distancing, wearing masks.
大家好。我想这会很简短。这完全是我们不应该做的事情的对立面。我们本应该保持物理距离，佩戴口罩。
[BOOING]
[嘘声]
And so--
所以——
[BOOING]
[嘘声]
--all of our medical--
——我们所有的医学——
[BOOING]
[嘘声]
All of our medical experts--
我们所有的医学专家——
Let him talk!
让他说话！
Our department of health--
我们的卫生部门——
You've already made your decision?
你已经做出了决定？
Everyone is encouraging us to do that. This room is not complying with these health guidelines. This creates a health concern for this meeting, so--
每个人都在鼓励我们这样做。这个房间没有遵守这些健康指南。这为这次会议制造了健康隐患，所以——
[SHOUTING]
[叫喊声]
In a little over a minute, the whole meeting was over.
在不到一分钟的时间里，整个会议就结束了。
OK, the meeting is adjourned.
好了，会议休会。
[SHOUTING]
[叫喊声]
Ainge stands up and walks out of the building. People in the crowd call him a coward.
艾恩奇站起来走出了大楼。人群里的人叫他懦夫。
Yeah, Tanner is a coward.
是的，坦纳是个懦夫。
And then--
然后——
USA! USA! USA!
美国！美国！美国！
Ainge later tweeted, "This is not a Parks and Rec episode. It's Utah County government." To him, this whole thing was just a political stunt. The county commission has no jurisdiction over school districts. They don't make decisions for them. It'd be like the sheriff's department holding a meeting to vote on the school budget. It didn't make any sense.
艾恩奇后来发推文说：“这不是《公园与游憩》的剧集。这是犹他县政府。”对他来说，这一切只是一个政治噱头。县委员会对学区没有管辖权。他们不为学校做决定。这就像治安官部门举行会议投票决定学校预算一样。这毫无意义。
But Billy, the guy who wanted the governor to give the county a compassionate exemption from wearing masks, and another commissioner, they agreed to stay behind to listen to any parent who wanted to make a comment. Again, here's Bayley.
但是比利，那个想要州长给县里提供戴口罩的同情豁免权的家伙，还有另一位专员，他们同意留下来听取任何想要发表评论的家长的意见。再次，这是贝莉。
At that point, when I realized that people were going to be making comments, I kind of pushed my way into the room because I wanted to make a comment.
在那一刻，当我意识到人们要发表评论时，我挤进了房间，因为我也想发表评论。
She got in line for the podium. There were around 12 people ahead of her, even more behind her, mostly moms. One of them had a baby carrier strapped to her chest. I watched this meeting on a Facebook livestream.
她排队等候发言台。前面大约有12个人，后面更多，大多是妈妈。其中一个怀里还绑着婴儿背带。我在Facebook直播上看了这个会议。
Most of the speakers accepted that COVID is real. They didn't think it's a hoax. They supported hand washing and staying at home if you're sick. But they didn't trust the CDC, and in general all the precautions seemed overblown.
大多数发言者承认新冠是真实存在的。他们不认为这是骗局。他们支持洗手并在生病时呆在家里。但他们不信任疾控中心，总的来说，所有的预防措施似乎都被夸大了。
Some sounded like libertarians. There were tons of conspiracy theories. Like that mom with the baby, she said this thing I heard a lot of parents there say, that CO2 and germs can get trapped in your mask and make you sick, which is totally false.
有些人听起来像自由意志主义者。有大量的阴谋论。比如那个抱着婴儿的妈妈，她说了我在那里听到的很多家长常说的话，就是二氧化碳和细菌会被困在口罩里让你生病，这完全是假的。
You want our kids to breathe their own CO2?
你们想让我们的孩子呼吸他们自己的二氧化碳吗？
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
That's right!
说得对！
Do you really think it's good to breathe in your own germs for hours?
你真的认为呼吸自己的细菌几个小时是好事吗？
She's saying, do you really think it's good to breathe in your own germs for hours?
她说，你真的认为呼吸自己的细菌几个小时是好事吗？
Amen, sister.
阿门，姐妹。
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
This myth has taken off in parent groups all over the country. The American Academy of Pediatrics even put out a statement to try and dispel it. And another conspiracy theory at this meeting, that mask mandates will lead to more kids getting abducted and sex trafficked-- also not true. The fear is that if kids are wearing masks, they'll be harder to identify and rescue.
这个谬论在全国各地的家长群体中流行开来。美国儿科学会甚至发表了一份声明试图消除它。会议上还有另一个阴谋论，即强制戴口罩会导致更多的孩子被绑架和人口贩卖——这也是错误的。恐惧在于，如果孩子戴着口罩，他们将更难被识别和营救。
Those numbers will continue to rise because of a world are at home and online all day and being masked. It's a pedophile's dream come true.
由于世界全天都在家里和网上，而且戴着口罩，这些数字将会持续上升。这是恋童癖者梦想成真。
Thomas Jefferson also kept coming up in this pretty ironic way.
托马斯·杰斐逊也以这种相当讽刺的方式不断被提及。
I got on my Facebook page. Thomas Jefferson said, I prefer dangerous freedom over peaceful slavery. I will never be a slave, no matter what it takes. Give me liberty, or give me death. I mean that. I will do whatever it takes to have liberty. Thank you.
我上了我的Facebook页面。托马斯·杰斐逊说，我更喜欢危险的自由，而不是和平的奴役。我永远不会成为奴隶，无论付出什么代价。不自由，毋宁死。我是认真的。无论付出什么代价，我都要获得自由。谢谢。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Listening to all these parents, Bayley and Clark were alarmed, worried that they might have to face classes of 40 kids who were going to fight with them about wearing masks. So Bayley, she got up to the mic. She was sweaty and nervous, but fired up.
听着所有这些家长的声音，贝莉和克拉克感到很惊恐，担心他们可能会面对40个要和他们争吵是否戴口罩的孩子。所以贝莉走到麦克风前。她又汗又紧张，但斗志昂扬。
My name is Bayley. I'm experiencing fear and anxiety about many things.
我叫贝莉。我对许多事情感到恐惧和焦虑。
She tells the crowd she's a first-year teacher who's already juggling a lot of anxiety, and she's scared that she'll get COVID in her classroom. The crowd turns on her.
她告诉人群她是一名一年级老师，已经承受了很多焦虑，她害怕自己在课堂上感染新冠。人群开始攻击她。
Wearing a mask is a minor inconvenience, if you can even call it that.
戴口罩是一个轻微的不便，如果这也能叫不便的话。
Who says?
谁说的？
Sh.
嘘。
That's Clark, doing some very teacher-like shushing.
那是克拉克，在做一些非常像老师的“嘘”声动作。
Hey! Sh.
嘿！嘘。
I am honestly shocked right now by your behavior.
说实话，我现在对你们的行为感到震惊。
You should be.
你应该感到震惊。
I'm frankly so shocked that so many people have come out to oppose such a simple, harmless act.
坦率地说，我非常震惊，竟然有这么多人出来反对这样一个简单、无害的行为。
We gave you your time. Be quiet. Shut up. Listen.
我们给了你时间。安静。闭嘴。听着。
It's like this for five minutes, and then Bayley finally ends her speech and takes a little bow.
大概持续了五分钟，贝莉终于结束了演讲，鞠了个小躬。
[BOOING]
[嘘声]
On their way out of the meeting, Clark, feeling sheepish, apologizes to the people that he told to shut up.
在他们离开会议的路上，克拉克感到尴尬，向那些被他叫“闭嘴”的人道歉。
That was my wife out there... I'm sorry. Thank you.
那是我的妻子……我很抱歉。谢谢。
I've never been booed before. It was just wild to be surrounded by so many grown adults who were shouting at me, calling me names. It was like, whoa. Also re-watching the video, I realized that I kind of did, like, a little bow after my comments, which is kind of embarrassing now. But it was just like-- it felt like such an outrageous experience, and it was almost comical.
我以前从没被人嘘过。被那么多成年人包围，对我大喊大叫，叫我各种名字，真是太狂野了。就像是，哇。事后看视频，我意识到我在评论后还鞠了个小躬，现在想来有点尴尬。但这感觉就像是一次极其离谱的经历，几乎是滑稽的。
But Bayley was also sympathetic to the parents in that room. She thought a lot of their hostility was coming from a place of fear.
但贝莉对那个房间里的家长也表示同情。她认为他们的敌意很大程度上源于恐惧。
You know, like not wanting kids to have to be in schools where things feel very dystopian and like this fear that having to be masked is going to scare their children or something like that or impact them negatively. I feel like those are reasonable points in some ways, but also not at the same time.
你知道，就像不想让孩子待在感觉非常反乌托邦的学校里，或者担心必须戴口罩会吓坏孩子之类的，或者产生负面影响。我觉得这些在某种程度上是合理的观点，但同时也不是。
I grew up in Utah County. I still have a lot of friends and family there. So I feel pretty safe betting that most of the people in that meeting were Mormon. The majority of the county belongs to the church.
我在犹他县长大。我在那里还有很多朋友和家人。所以我很有把握地认为，会议上的大多数人都是摩门教徒。该县大部分人口属于该教会。
But watching that meeting, I saw something I didn't recognize-- Mormons yelling at other Mormons with total vitriol. Bayley and Clark said they felt the same. They're from the area too. By the way, I know we're not supposed to say Mormon anymore. We're supposed to say Latter-day Saint. But I just don't actually know that many Mormons who use that with each other.
但在观看那个会议时，我看到了我不认识的东西——摩门教徒带着极大的刻薄在对其他摩门教徒大喊大叫。贝莉和克拉克说他们也有同样的感觉。他们也来自那个地区。顺便说一下，我知道我们不应该再说摩门教徒了。我们应该说耶稣基督后期圣徒教会成员。但我真的认识的不多用那个称呼彼此。
Anyway, right after Utah's Republican Governor Gary Herbert issued his mask mandate, church leadership in the state backed him up. They asked Mormons to wear face coverings in public, calling it a sign of good citizenship. Immediately there was pushback. I saw comments online about corruption and false prophets in the church. That was mind-blowing. It's not like members never speak out against the church. It's just that I haven't seen it done so casually.
不管怎样，就在犹他州共和党州长加里·赫伯特发布口罩令后，该州的教会领导层支持了他。他们要求摩门教徒在公共场合遮盖面部，称这是良好公民身份的标志。立刻就出现了抵制。我在网上看到了关于教会内部腐败和假先知的评论。这真是令人大开眼界。并不是说成员们从不公开反对教会。只是我还没见过做得这么随意的。
Pro-mask people were called maskers and mask-holes. Governor Herbert called the parents who went to that county meeting foolish, and he refused to back down from his mask mandate, which just enraged the anti-mask movement in Utah County even more. They held another rally and told parents to tell their kids to fight back against their teachers.
支持口罩的人被称为“口罩党”和“口罩混蛋”。赫伯特州长称去参加县会议的家长是愚蠢的，他拒绝撤销他的口罩令，这让犹他县的反口罩运动更加愤怒。他们举行了另一场集会，告诉家长让孩子去反抗老师。
Bayley and Clark wondered how widespread the feeling was and worried that some of the parents or fellow teachers at her new school would recognize Bayley from the county meeting and think she was a crazy radical. Video had hit local news, and it was a big deal.
贝莉和克拉克想知道这种情绪有多普遍，并担心她新学校里的一些家长或同事老师会认出贝莉就是县会议上的那个人，并认为她是激进分子。视频已经在当地新闻中播出，这是一件大事。
Have you thought about what you're going to say in your classes on the first day, anticipating you might have kids who come from families that share some of the same beliefs of the people who were at the county meeting?
你想过在第一天的课上说什么吗？如果预料到会有学生来自和县会议上的人有相同信仰的家庭？
I really don't know what I'm going to say or how I'm going to approach that conversation.
我真的不知道要说什么，也不知道该怎么处理那个对话。
Yeah.
是的。
We really don't know what this is going to look like when the school year actually starts. And so we'll see what happens then.
我们真的不知道开学时会是什么样子。所以到时候看看会发生什么吧。
What if you get booed?
如果你被嘘了怎么办？
I will bow and walk out. [LAUGHS]
我会鞠个躬走人。[笑]
On the first day of school, Bayley and Clark got in their cars and headed in opposite directions. Their schools are about a half hour apart. They both recorded voice memos for me while they were driving.
开学第一天，贝莉和克拉克坐上车，向相反方向驶去。他们的学校相距大约半小时路程。他们开车时都给我录了语音备忘录。
OK. I am driving to school for my first day of teaching ever in my whole life as an actual teacher. So there's kind of a mix of feeling excited and also nervous. Hopefully I can remember students' faces through their masks.
好的。我正在开车去学校，这是我一生中作为一名真正老师的第一天。所以心情有点兴奋，也有点紧张。希望我能透过他们的口罩记住学生们的脸。
The time is now 6:36. And I didn't sleep very well last night. I kind of tossed and turned. Worst case scenario today-- oh my gosh, I think I had a nightmare about that last night, where everybody came in and just was touching each other, and hugging each other, and not wearing masks. And I think there was a couple that was making out in the corner of my classroom-- just so much touching.
现在时间是6点36分。我昨晚睡得不太好。翻来覆去。今天最坏的情况——天哪，昨晚我好像做了个关于这个的噩梦，所有人进来就开始互相触摸、拥抱，而且没戴口罩。我想还有一个情侣在教室角落里亲热——实在是太多的接触。
And so I'm hoping students will wear masks today. I'm hoping I won't have any major conflicts with students as they come in. Judging on the anti-mask hearing that Bayley and I went to, I mean, all bets are off.
所以我希望学生今天会戴口罩。我希望在他们进来时不会和学生发生重大冲突。从贝莉和我参加的反口罩听证会来看，好吧，一切皆有可能。
[STUDENTS CHATTERING]
[学生聊天声]
As students walk into his classroom, Clark stands at the door to greet them and squeezes hand sanitizer into their hands.
当学生走进他的教室时，克拉克站在门口迎接他们，并把洗手液挤进他们手里。
Hi, guys. Hand sanitizer coming in hot. There you go.
嘿，伙计们。洗手液来了。给你们。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Hey, dude, hand sanitizer.
嘿，伙计，洗手液。
Clark describes his teaching persona as dorky dad. Once everyone is seated, he gives his warm-up.
克拉克把自己的教学人设形容为呆萌老爸。一旦大家都坐好了，他开始暖场。
Hello, everyone. Welcome. How are you guys feeling today? Are you feeling excited to be here? Raise your hand if you're excited. [LAUGHS NERVOUSLY]
大家好。欢迎。你们今天感觉怎么样？你们感到兴奋吗？如果你兴奋，请举手。[尴尬地笑]
This is awkward. In a class of 36 kids, only a few of them raise their hands. He had never taught a class that was so quiet and somber.
这太尴尬了。在一个有36个孩子的班级里，只有几个举手。他从没教过这么安静和沉闷的班级。
Raise your hand if you're just kind of like stressed and sad. [LAUGHS NERVOUSLY] Few of you. Is anybody feeling anxious about wearing masks or feeling bummed about wearing masks? A little bit?
如果你感到压力大和难过，请举手。[尴尬地笑] 你们几个。有人因为戴口罩感到焦虑或因为戴口罩感到沮丧吗？有一点点吗？
I'm bummed about wearing masks.
我对戴口罩感到沮丧。
Yeah, tell me more. You're bummed about wearing masks? It sucks? Tell me more. Why does it suck?
是的，告诉我更多。你因为戴口罩感到沮丧？这很糟糕？告诉我更多。为什么糟糕？
I don't know.
我不知道。
The student says, I don't know. I just don't feel like it sometimes. And then, my dad talks about it all the time. It's just to make people feel better. Clark responds deftly by first trying to validate the student.
学生说，我不知道。我只是有时不想戴。而且，我爸爸一直在说这个。这只是为了让别人感觉好点。克拉克机智地回应，首先试图认可学生的感受。
Yeah, I mean, from a medical standpoint masks are definitely not perfect. If we really wanted to prevent every single germ, we'd have to wear full hazmat suits. We'd have to be in a controlled environment. So masks are not 100% effective. However, they are effective in stopping the spread or slowing the spread of these.
是的，我是说，从医学角度看，口罩绝对不是完美的。如果我们真的想预防每一个细菌，我们就得穿全身防护服。我们得处于受控环境中。所以口罩不是100%有效的。然而，它们在阻止传播或减缓这些病毒的传播方面是有效的。
And so I know a lot of people are really, really frustrated about wearing masks because they're uncomfortable, and they make breathing hard, and blah, blah, blah. Even though they're not perfect, I think it's worth doing as a gesture of kindness toward people who might have more sensitive immune systems or might be more at risk. I was just barely talking with a student who lives with her grandma, and also works at a nursing home. And so she's trying to take every precaution to make sure that she doesn't get sick. So there are a lot of situations like that.
我知道很多人真的非常、非常因戴口罩而沮丧，因为它们不舒服，让呼吸变得困难等等。尽管它们不完美，但我认为作为一种对那些免疫系统更敏感或风险更高的人的善意表现，这样做是值得的。我刚才和一名学生谈话，她和奶奶住在一起，还在养老院工作。所以她正在尽一切努力确保自己不会生病。所以有很多这样的情况。
Little by little, his class starts to open up. Clark keeps lobbing questions at them. Anybody here play sports? A football player tells the room that his whole team wears masks for games and practice. A girl says she hates it, that they make her glasses fog up. About 15 minutes into this conversation, Clark uses the tactic that didn't work with the parents at the county meeting. He tells them about his own anxiety.
一点一点地，他的班级开始敞开心扉。克拉克不断向他们抛出问题。这里有人参加体育运动吗？一名橄榄球运动员告诉大家，他的整个团队在比赛和练习时都戴着口罩。一个女孩说她讨厌它，因为这让她的眼镜起雾。谈话进行了大约15分钟，克拉克使用了在县会议上对家长没奏效的战术。他告诉了他们关于他自己的焦虑。
That's been one of my anxieties coming back to school, is I don't want to have to tell somebody to wear a mask. You know? That feels stressful to me.
那是回到学校后我的焦虑之一，就是我不想不得不告诉别人戴口罩。你知道吗？这让我感到压力。
And the kids, they seem to get it. Clark has two other periods that day, and he starts each class with the same soapbox spiel. He never gets any push back. The kids all wear their masks, and nobody makes out.
孩子们似乎明白了。克拉克那天还有其他两节课，他每节课都以同样的演讲开始。他从未遇到任何反对。孩子们都戴着口罩，也没有人亲热。
After school, Clark and Bayley crash exhausted on their living room couch with their dog and debrief about how their first days went.
放学后，克拉克和贝莉筋疲力尽地和他们的狗倒在客厅沙发上，总结第一天的情况。
The hallways were just kind of the wild, wild West.
走廊简直就是狂野西部。
Yeah.
是的。
Like, anything went. And so many students, as soon as they left their classrooms, would just peel their masks off and put it around their chin--
就像，什么样的事都有。太多的学生，一离开教室，就会把口罩摘下来挂在下巴上——
What?
什么？
Or just rip it off their faces. And then as they walk closer to me, I'd say, hey, masks. And they would say, oh, yeah, sorry, I forgot, and then hurry and put it back on. And they'd put it back on as they walked into my classroom. I mean, there's just no way that the hall monitors can see everything that's going on.
或者直接从脸上扯下来。当他们朝我走近时，我会说，嘿，口罩。他们会说，哦，好的，抱歉，我忘了，然后匆忙戴回去。他们走进我的教室时又戴好了。我的意思是，巡逻的老师不可能看到正在发生的一切。
Yeah.
是的。
When you talked about masks, how did you approach the mask conversation?
当你谈论口罩时，你是怎么处理口罩对话的？
They walk in the door. You're like, hi. And they just look at you, or they're just like, hi. And you're just like, do you hate my guts?
他们走进门。你像是在说，嘿。他们只是看着你，或者就像说，嘿。你就觉得，你恨透我了吗？
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
She told Clark she started class by showing them slides of Billie Eilish wearing a lace mask and Beyoncé wearing a mask upside down.
她告诉克拉克，她开始上课时给他们展示了碧梨戴着蕾丝口罩和碧昂丝戴着倒扣口罩的幻灯片。
And in my first class, everyone was totally fine. In my second and third classes, there were kids who kept wearing them under their nose. And I just had to keep being like, if you're not wearing your mask over your mouth and nose, wear your mask over your mouth and nose.
在我的第一个班，每个人都完全没问题。在我的第二和第三个班，有孩子一直把口罩戴在鼻子下面。我不得不一直说，如果你没有把口罩戴在嘴和鼻子上，就把口罩戴在嘴和鼻子上。
I had to call out a couple kids today because they just kept on letting their nose stick out.
我今天不得不点名几个孩子，因为他们一直让鼻子露出来。
Yeah.
是的。
And I was like-- [SNAPS FINGERS] --hey, Cody, Josh. Cover your nose up.
我就像这样——[弹指]——嘿，科迪，乔什。把你的鼻子盖上。
Cody and Josh.
科迪和乔什。
Yeah.
是的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Oh, also, there was a kid who was wearing a full yellow hazmat suit with like a gas mask-looking thing. And I think it was like a joke, but it also was hard to tell. And my friend who was his teacher said that it looked like he was just dying in there, like so hot.
哦，还有，有一个孩子穿着一套完整的黄色防护服，戴着那种看起来像防毒面具的东西。我想这像是个笑话，但也很难说。我的朋友是他的老师，她说看起来他简直要在里面热死了，太热了。
And there was another girl wearing a mask in one of my classes-- apparently this is a thing that I didn't know about, but she was wearing a mask that said "Virginity rocks." So I don't know what that's about, but it was funny to see that on a mask. That's the extent of Utah's sex education.
还有一个女孩在我的一个班里戴着口罩——显然这是一件我不知道的事情，但她戴着一个写着“处女很酷”的口罩。所以我不知道那是怎么回事，但在口罩上看到那个很有趣。这就是犹他州性教育的程度。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Totally.
完全正确。
Oh, man. It was a wild thing. I don't know. I was thinking about it after school today, and I was just comparing these sweet sophomore students to the parents who were in that meeting. And like, oh my gosh, these cutie, cutie high school students are just so nice, and so willing to just do this thing so they can be in school. And all those parents were just losing their minds and being so childish and unreasonable. I don't know. It just was really nice.
天哪。那真是个疯狂的事情。我不知道。放学后我一直在想，我把这些甜蜜的十年级学生和会议上的家长做了比较。就像，天哪，这些可爱的、可爱的中学生是如此友好，如此愿意做这件事，以便他们能上学。而那些家长却在失去理智，表现得如此幼稚和不合理。我不知道。这真的很好。
[LAUGHS] Are you tearing up a little bit?
[笑] 你是在流泪吗？
Yeah, a little bit. I don't know why.
是的，有点。我不知道为什么。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Just really nice students who want to be at school.
只是非常好的想上学的学生。
The reality is that more than half a million people live in Utah County, and only 100 people were at that meeting. The consensus among most parents is that they'll make their kids wear masks if it gets them out of the house.
现实是犹他县有超过50万人口，只有100人参加了那个会议。大多数家长的共识是，如果能让他们出门，他们就会让孩子戴口罩。
Miki Meek is one of the producers of our show.
米基·米克是我们节目的制作人之一。
Act Two, Screen Times at Ridgemont High. So across the country right now, kids are facing the weird experience of getting to know new classes and new teachers, all through Zoom. It's especially intense for kids who are jumping into a new school.
第二幕，里奇蒙高中的屏幕时间。在全国范围内，孩子们现在正面临着通过Zoom了解新课程和新老师的奇怪体验。对于那些今年秋天跳级进入新学校的孩子来说，这尤其强烈。
Producer Aviva DeKornfeld talked to some students who are making the jump to high school this fall, and it is a big job, right? It's one that causes a lot of anxiety and excitement in normal times. Now, all of it happening online. One girl told Aviva that she'd already thought through how to make friends at her new school.
制作人阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德采访了一些今年秋天进入高中的孩子，这是一个巨大的转变，对吧？在正常时期，这会引起很多焦虑和兴奋。现在，一切都在网上发生。一个女孩告诉阿维瓦，她已经想好如何在她的新学校交朋友了。
She said she had a plan to email kids to discuss homework, and then she would try to shift the conversation to other topics and see if they went there. And Aviva talked to this 15-year-old in Los Angeles, Alex Hymen, at the end of his very first day of high school about how he's prepped for remote learning with a bunch of kids that he doesn't know.
她说她有个计划，给孩子们发邮件讨论作业，然后她会试图把对话转移到其他话题，看看他们是否会接话。在高中第一天结束时，阿维瓦采访了洛杉矶的15岁学生亚历克斯·海曼，关于他如何准备与一群他不认识的孩子进行远程学习。
This week, I'm painting my room. I actually just finished this morning.
这周，我正在粉刷我的房间。我实际上今天早上刚完成。
Why are you painting your room?
你为什么要粉刷你的房间？
Well, last year in the spring, when online school started in March or April, believe it or not, a lot of kids made comments on my bright, vibrant baby blue and orange room that I've had since when I was very young. And I thought it'd be cool to have a multicolored room, very bright.
好吧，去年春天，当线上学校在三月或四月开始时，信不信由你，很多孩子对我有亮丽、充满活力的婴儿蓝和橙色的房间发表了评论，那个房间我从很小的时候就有了。我以为有一个五颜六色、非常明亮的房间会很酷。
What do kids say?
孩子们说什么？
They were just like, nice room. Like, oh, that's a very neutral color, just sarcastic comments like that. I mean, it's a very first-world problem that my room's not the right color.
他们只是说，不错的房间。像是，哦，那是很中性的颜色，那种讽刺的评论。我的意思是，这是一个非常“第一世界”的问题，我的房间颜色不对。
How old were you when you first painted it, the bright colors?
你第一次粉刷它，也就是亮色时，你多大？
I believe I was, like, seven, eight. I was like, yes, it's going to be so cool and awesome. And now here I'm 15, and now I just want a white room. Now, actually-- I just finished this morning. Now it's all the light gray I picked out, and I actually like it a lot. My mom was a little sad because I'm growing up, and she was upset about that.
我相信我当时大概七、八岁。我心想，是的，那会非常酷和棒。现在我15岁了，现在我只想有一个白色的房间。实际上——我今天早上刚完成。现在是我挑选的浅灰色，我真的很喜欢它。我妈妈有点伤心，因为我在成长，她对此感到难过。
Oh. What did she say?
哦。她说了什么？
I mean, she was like, I'm going to miss this room. Like, remember when you picked out the colors and--
我的意思是，她说，我会想念这个房间的。就像，记得当你挑选颜色时……
Yeah. It's funny, your mom was upset that you're growing up. And you're like, that's the point.
是的。真有趣，你妈妈因为你长大而难过。而你却说，重点就在这。
Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
是的，完全正确。是的。
So you were on Zoom calls today. Did you look at your little box on Zoom--
所以你今天在Zoom通话上。你看过你在Zoom上的小方块吗——
Yeah.
是的。
--to check out how it looked?
——去看看它看起来怎么样？
Yeah, I did. I did.
是的，我看过。我看过。
How did it feel seeing your room in the camera?
在镜头里看到你的房间感觉如何？
It looked very good, I will say. It looked very cool. I was happy about it.
它看起来非常好，我得说。看起来很酷。我对此很开心。
Did the other kids have childhood stuff in their bedrooms?
其他孩子的卧室里有童年的东西吗？
I don't really pay much attention to it, along with them not really paying attention to me, which is weird because even though we both know that, it still makes us feel self-conscious about it. That probably didn't make any sense. What I'm trying to say is that I look at some of them, but I don't really analyze the rooms.
我真的没太注意，加上他们也没怎么注意我，这很奇怪，因为即使我们都知道，它还是会让我们对它感到自我意识。那可能没什么意义。我想说的是，我看着他们中的一些人，但我并没有真正分析房间。
You didn't really pay much attention.
你没太注意。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
Looking at the other kids' rooms and realizing you don't actually really care about how they look, did it make you feel like it didn't matter if you had switched up your room or not?
看着其他孩子的房间，意识到你其实并不在乎它们看起来怎么样，这是否让你觉得你是否更换房间颜色并不重要？
Yeah, it actually did sort of.
是的，确实有点。
What's the first thing you saw today at school?
你今天在学校看到的第一件事是什么？
I logged on, and it was our whole grade, so around a little less than 200. I'm not sure of the exact number. But yeah, it was a bunch of boxes. Most of the kids-- or I guess half the kids had their cameras on. Half had them off. I started with mine on and then turned it off, to be honest.
我登录了，是我们整个年级，所以大概不到200人。我不确定确切数字。但是的，是一堆方块。大多数孩子——或者我猜一半的孩子开了摄像头。一半关着。老实说，我开始是开着的，后来关了。
Really? Why?
真的吗？为什么？
I guess it just-- a lot of other kids had it off, like most them towards the end. And I didn't want to be the one kid that had it on, if that makes sense.
我猜它只是……很多其他孩子都关了，大多数人在最后都关了。我不想成为唯一开着摄像头的孩子，如果这有意义的话。
So you sort of took your cue from the other kids.
所以你从其他孩子那里得到了暗示。
Yeah, exactly. Peer pressure, I guess.
是的，完全正确。我想是同伴压力吧。
Aviva DeKornfeld talking to Alex Hymen in Los Angeles. Aviva's one of the producers of our show. Coming up, an elementary school that carefully did everything you could possibly do to prepare for students coming back. And then first day, it all goes south in a way nobody ever expected. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德在洛杉矶与亚历克斯·海曼交谈。阿维瓦是我们节目的制作人之一。接下来，一所小学非常仔细地做了所有可能做的准备工作，迎接学生回归。然后第一天，事情以没人预料到的方式变糟了。这将在芝加哥公共广播公司节目继续后的一分钟内播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program is about schools reopening this fall. And can I say, of all the cataclysmic things that happened this past week around our country-- wildfires, Hurricane Laura, the shootings in Kenosha-- school reopenings was on the calendar. You know, it's the one thing out of all those things that we knew would happen and had time to prepare for, and still it somehow feels like the whole summer has been an all-nighter for a test that we're having this fall, and lots of parents and educators are feeling very shaky about how the test is going to go.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是关于今年秋天学校重新开放。我可以这样说吗，在过去一周全国发生的那么多灾难性事件中——野火、劳拉飓风、基诺沙的枪击事件——学校重开也在日程表上。你知道，在所有这些事件中，这是我们知道会发生并且有时间准备的一件事，但不知何故，它感觉就像整个夏天都在为今年秋天的一场测试熬夜，很多家长和教育工作者对这场测试将如何进行感到非常动摇。
How it is going is what we're documenting on today's show. And we have arrived at Act Three of our program--
它是如何进行的正是我们在今天节目中记录的内容。我们已经进入了节目的第三幕——
Act Three, Future Imperfect. This next story is from a high school in Tennessee, Maryville High School. This is one of the first in the country to open up. And it opened as cases were rising in the area.
第三幕，不完美的未来。下一个故事来自田纳西州的一所高中，玛丽维尔高中。这是全国最早开放的学校之一。而且它在当地病例上升时开放了。
On the COVID map that Harvard Global Health Institute maintains, the county is currently red as we get today's show on the air. Red, the institute says, means that they're at a tipping point for uncontrolled spread. That's exactly the kind of situation that lots of teachers around the country have been saying would keep them from returning to their classrooms. Maryville, however, has been at it for a month now.
在哈佛全球健康研究所维护的新冠地图上，当我们播出今天节目时，该县目前是红色。研究所说，红色意味着他们处于不受控制传播的临界点。这正是全国各地许多老师一直说会阻止他们回到教室的那种情况。然而，玛丽维尔已经这样一个月了。
So what's it like? How are they holding up? For a glimpse of the future that awaits many educators elsewhere, David Kestenbaum talked with a teacher named Stacey Travis.
那么感觉如何？他们如何坚持下去？为了窥探等待其他地方教育工作者的未来，大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆与一位名叫斯泰西·特拉维斯的老师进行了交谈。
Stacey is the kind of teacher people go to when they have problems. A lot of the time they're math problems. That's what she teaches. One of the days we talked, she got a call in the middle of the day from a kid who wasn't even in school that year. He'd graduated. He was in his dorm room in college.
斯泰西是那种遇到问题时人们会去找的老师。很多时候他们是数学问题。那是她教的科目。我们谈话的一天，她白天接到了一个当年的学生打来的电话，那个学生甚至不在学校里了。他毕业了。他在大学宿舍里。
And so I call him back, and he was like, I don't know how to solve this. And he shows me this paper. And I said, what class are you in? And he goes, freshman engineering. And I said, I taught you how to solve that. He goes, I know. That's why I called you.
所以我回电话给他，他说，我不知道怎么解决这个问题。他给我看了这张纸。我说，你上什么课？他说，大一工程学。我说，我教过你怎么解那个。他说，我知道。那就是我找你的原因。
The decision to go back to school in the middle of a pandemic, it's a different kind of problem. Even before school opened, there were cases. Some kids couldn't come in on the first day because they tested positive. And she says a couple teachers have taken these extra precautions in their classrooms.
在大流行期间重返学校的决定，是另一种问题。甚至在学校开放之前，就有病例了。有些孩子因为检测呈阳性第一天没能来。她说有几位老师在教室里采取了这些额外的预防措施。
Like one has this-- it almost looks like the old-fashioned bathtubs with the ring around it with the curtain, and it goes all the way around their desk.
比如一个人有这个——它看起来几乎像旧式浴缸，周围带着环和帘子，一直围着他们的桌子。
Wait, wait. So the teacher's desk is basically surrounded with, like, a shower curtain?
等等，等等。所以老师的桌子基本上是被，像是淋浴帘包围着？
Clear shower curtain on PVC pipe.
PVC管上的透明淋浴帘。
Even with all the masks and social distancing, Stacey says school feels kind of normal once the day gets started. But there's always this menace that feels just offstage. Since the high school opened, several students have tested positive. She gets an email every time. When we talked, she had one student out awaiting test results. It doesn't look like any of the students got the virus from school, but there has been one case in the district where it looks like a maintenance worker may have gotten COVID from a colleague.
即使戴着口罩和社交距离，斯泰西说一旦开始一天，学校感觉还是挺正常的。但总有一种感觉就在舞台外的威胁。自从高中开放以来，几名学生检测呈阳性。她每次都收到电子邮件。我们谈话时，她有一名学生在等待检测结果。看起来没有任何学生是从学校感染病毒的，但在学区确实有一个案例，看起来像是维护人员可能从同事那里感染了新冠。
There are moments that it worries me, and I can give you a specific example. I had a student ask for help. And I had my mask on. I have my mask on every time I walk up close to a student to offer help.
有些时刻让我担心，我可以给你举个具体的例子。我有一个学生寻求帮助。我戴着口罩。每次我走近学生提供帮助时，我都戴着口罩。
And he had his mask on, but had it below his nose. And I was writing on his desk, and we were talking through this problem. And I could feel his breath on my arm. And that kind of made me have a moment of, oh, my gosh, he's breathing on me. I can feel the breath coming out of his nose, onto my arm.
他戴着口罩，但在鼻子下面。我在他的桌子上写字，我们正在讨论这个问题。我能感觉到他的呼吸在我手臂上。那一刻让我有点，哦，天哪，他在我身上呼吸。我能感觉到呼吸从他鼻子里出来，落在我的手臂上。
And after I finished helping him, which I do this after I help any kid at their desk, I sanitized my hands. But then I also have some spray sanitizer, and I just sprayed it down my arm. And I know it probably looked weird, and I wasn't trying to make him feel uncomfortable, but it made me feel a little bit better.
在我帮他完成之后，我都会帮任何孩子在桌上帮忙后这样做，我洗了手。但我还有一些喷雾消毒剂，我就直接喷在我的手臂上。我知道它看起来可能很奇怪，我不是想让他感到不舒服，但这让我感觉好了一点。
Do you think about the question of sort of risk with math ever--
你考虑过关于风险和数学的问题吗——
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
--since you're a math person?
——因为你是数学人？
As the risk of me catching COVID--
关于我感染新冠的风险——
Yeah. I don't know.
是的。我不知道。
--doing my job? Yeah.
——做我的工作？是的。
Yeah. There are this many positive cases in the community or this many people in school over this period of time. I'm in contact with this number of them. You could do the numbers.
是的。社区里有这么多阳性病例，或者在这段时间里学校有这么多人。我接触的人数是这么多。你可以算一下数字。
Oh, yeah. I could definitely do the numbers. I don't let myself do the numbers, because I think I've just kind of realized that I'm probably going to get it. Either I'm going to get it from a student, or I'm going to get it from my kid who got it from another kid.
哦，是的。我绝对可以算一下数字。我不让自己算，因为我想我只是意识到我可能要感染了。要么是我从学生那里感染的，要么是从我从另一个孩子那里感染的孩子那里感染的。
Yeah.
是的。
Or I'm going to get it from my husband who got it from one of the workers on his job site.
或者我会从我丈夫那里感染，他从他工作现场的一个工人那里感染的。
What do you think about that? It might be OK, but it might not.
你怎么看？这可能是好的，也可能不是。
I know. I know. It might be OK, and it might not. And again, it's one of those-- the what-ifs that I can't just let myself think about.
我知道。我知道。这可能是好的，也可能不是。再说一次，这是那种……我无法让自己去想的“假设”。
That's a kind of amazing degree of fatalism. Somehow we're at a place where simply by doing her job she feels sure she's going to get sick.
这是一种惊人的宿命论程度。不知何故，我们处于这样一个地方，仅仅通过做她的工作，她就确信她会生病。
There are moments that I am super scared about getting it. There are moments that I wonder, if I do get it, what's going to happen to my kids? Of course there's moments like that. I don't know. All of the conversations are hard, no matter what way you look at it.
有些时刻我非常害怕感染。有些时刻我想，如果我感染了，我的孩子会怎么样？当然有那样的时刻。我不知道。无论你从哪个角度看，所有的谈话都很艰难。
It's like the virus is this thing that you think about, then don't think about. Then you worry that you're not thinking about it.
这就像病毒是那种你思考，然后不思考的东西。然后你担心你没在想它。
I wanted to see what a class was actually like, given all this. Here's how things work. If your last name begins with a letter between A and K, you come in Monday and Wednesday. On Tuesday and Thursday, you join the class by Zoom from home. If your last name begins with a letter between L and Z, it's the reverse. Friday, everybody is remote. I watched on Zoom as Stacey taught some juniors how to graph polynomials.
我想看看考虑到所有这些，一堂课实际上是什么样子。事情是这样运作的。如果你的姓氏首字母在A和K之间，你周一和周三来。周二和周四，你从家里通过Zoom加入课堂。如果你的姓氏首字母在L和Z之间，情况相反。周五，每个人远程。我在Zoom上看着斯泰西教一些大三学生如何绘制多项式图。
This is x going to positive infinity, and this is y going to positive infinity. Does that make sense to you?
这是x趋于正无穷大，这是y趋于正无穷大。这对你有意义吗？
It seemed to go pretty well, even for the kids who weren't in the room.
看起来进行得很好，即使对那些不在房间里的孩子也是如此。
Let me get a brave person from at home who wants to talk through it. Who's going to unmute? Y'all are going to make me call on you, aren't you?
让我从家里找个勇敢的人来谈谈。谁会取消静音？你们会让我点名，对吧？
I'll try it.
我试试。
Thank you, Emma, for being a brave soul. OK, what you got?
谢谢你，艾玛，成为勇敢的灵魂。好的，你有什么？
OK, so I know--
好的，我知道——
Given how well it went, I asked her why not have everybody be remote? Why take the risk of doing anything in person? She said teaching online, you miss a lot. It's much easier for kids to get lost. If they're in the room, she can keep tabs, walk around, look over their shoulders.
考虑到进行得有多好，我问她为什么不让每个人都远程？为什么承担任何线下做的风险？她说在线教学，你错过了很多。孩子们更容易迷失。如果他们在房间里，她可以密切关注，走动，看看他们的肩膀。
And lots of kids do way better if they're there in person, interacting with other kids and with the teacher. There are kids who need extra attention. Just that day, she'd helped a student get through a test that he'd failed before, despite trying really hard.
很多孩子如果他们在现场，和老师以及其他孩子互动，会做得更好。有些孩子需要额外关注。就在那天，她帮一名学生通过了他之前失败的测试，尽管他非常努力。
I got to tell him face to face that I was proud of him. That's different. He looked at me, and I said, way to go, man. And we fist bumped. And he had a huge grin on his face. He knows that I've got his back.
我必须面对面告诉他我为他感到骄傲。那是不一样的。他看着我，我说，做得好，伙计。我们碰了碰拳头。他脸上露出了灿烂的笑容。他知道我支持他。
He had that victory moment. And that's the stuff that like-- that's why I feel a little bit on a high. These are the moments that I just live for.
他有那个胜利时刻。这就是……这就是为什么我感觉有点兴奋。这些就是我为之活着的时刻。
She was so happy, happy she was in school that day. She's there because the kids need her. I think it's also true that she needs them.
她很高兴，很高兴那天她在学校。她在那儿是因为孩子们需要她。我认为这也是真的，她需要他们。
David Kestenbaum is one of the producers of our show.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆是节目的制作人之一。
Act Four, The Case of the Well-Prepared Elementary School. So next, we go to a school that was remarkably ready for the first day, Tindley Summit Academy in Indianapolis. It's an elementary school, a charter school, pretty small, fewer than 300 students. And it was set up especially well to roll out all the new COVID safety precautions and procedures, because like lots of charter schools the whole philosophy of the school, from the kids all the way up to the principal, is very regimented. Kids walk silently in the hallways. There's a strict dress code, super involved teacher trainings.
第四幕，做好准备的小学案例。接下来，我们去一所为第一天准备得非常充分的学校，印第安纳波利斯的廷德利峰会学院。这是一所小学，一所特许学校，相当小，不到300名学生。它被建立得特别好，以推出所有新的新冠安全预防措施和程序，因为像许多特许学校一样，学校的全部理念，从孩子一直到校长，都非常严密。孩子们在走廊里静静地走。有严格的着装要求，非常投入的教师培训。
But even a place that could prepare so well, something big happened that first day that nobody saw coming. Stephanie Wang reports for a website that covers education that I am a fan of. It's called Chalk Beat. And for a month she watched Tindley Summit prepare for their reopening and then was there when the kids finally showed up.
但即使在准备得这么好的地方，第一天也发生了件大事，没人预料到。斯蒂芬妮·王为我喜欢的一个报道教育的网站做报道。它叫Chalk Beat。一个月来她看着廷德利峰会准备他们的重新开放，当孩子们终于出现时，她也在场。
Tindley Summit started the year with two weeks of online learning, but this is the moment everyone's been waiting for, the first day children are allowed back into the building for in-person instruction.
廷德利峰会以两周的在线学习开始了这一年，但这每个人都在等待的时刻，第一天孩子们被允许回到大楼进行线下教学。
Good morning.
早上好。
It's 7:30 in the morning, and parents are already lining up in the parking lot. Drop-off has been shortened to a frenzied 30-minute window to keep kids from gathering before classes start.
现在是早上7点30分，家长们已经在停车场排队了。接送时间缩短到疯狂的30分钟窗口，以防止孩子们在开始上课前聚集。
[CAR DOOR SHUTTING]
[车门关闭声]
[CAR HORN]
[汽车喇叭]
How are you, buddy?
你好吗，伙计？
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Good.
好的。
I like that mask.
我喜欢那个口罩。
A tiny first grader in a Spider-Man backpack named Karlo walks from the car to the front door, where a teacher leans down, aiming a handheld infrared thermometer at his forehead.
一个背着蜘蛛侠背包的名叫卡洛的瘦小一年级学生从车里走到前门，一位老师弯下腰，用手持红外测温仪对准他的额头。
Good morning, buddy. I'm going to take your temperature, OK? I just need to do one little click.
早上好，伙计。我要测一下你的体温，好吗？我只需要点一下。
[BEEPING]
[哔哔声]
All right, you're good to go.
好了，你可以进去了。
I'm standing with the principal of Tindley Summit, David McGuire, who's been planning for this moment for months, to get more than 200 children out of their cars and into the right classrooms in half an hour, all while keeping a safe distance. But Mr. McGuire is one of the most optimistic people I've ever interviewed. He doesn't like to worry or even use the word "worry." At one point when we're talking, he calls it the W word.
我和廷德利峰会的校长大卫·麦奎尔站在一起，他为这一刻策划了几个月，要在半小时内让200多个孩子从车里出来并进入正确的教室，同时保持安全距离。但麦奎尔先生是我采访过的最乐观的人之一。他不喜欢担心甚至使用“担心”这个词。有一次我们谈话时，他称它为W词。
I feel confident with our plan. And again, maybe day one we see how the plan goes. But I feel confident with the plan we have in place.
我对我们的计划感到自信。再说一次，也许第一天我们看看计划如何进行。但我对我们制定的计划感到自信。
Though he does admit to being a little W worded about the fact that they can't let parents into the building anymore and is concerned they'll get upset when they can't walk their little kids in. And as we're standing there, we watch how a mom named Pam Lee navigates that new reality. She's walking her sixth grader Nysia and kindergartner Ny'asia up to the door. It's Ny'asia's first in-person day of kindergarten.
尽管他确实承认对他们不能再让家长进入大楼这一事实感到有点W，并且担心当他们不能陪孩子进去时他们会感到不高兴。当我们站在那里时，我们看到一位名叫帕姆·李的妈妈如何处理那个新的现实。她带着她的六年级学生妮西亚和幼儿园学生奈娅西亚走向大门。这是奈娅西亚第一天线下上幼儿园。
Ny'asia. Ny'asia, you're going to be a big kindergartener, all right?
奈娅西亚。奈娅西亚，你要成为一个大幼儿园学生了，好吗？
She's a big girl now.
她现在是个大姑娘了。
All right. You're going to be good for Ms. Johnson, all right? All right, I will see you ladies later.
好的。在约翰逊老师那里你会表现好的，好吗？好了，女士们，回头见。
Just come in.
进来吧。
Just come in, Ny'asia pleads with her mom.
进来吧，奈娅西亚恳求她的妈妈。
I can't come in. I can't come in. Love you. Be a good girl, OK?
我不能进去。我不能进去。爱你。做个乖女孩，好吗？
As soon as she walks in the door, Ny'asia turns around. And she's just tall enough to peek out the bottom corner of the window in the door. She smiles big and waves to her mom.
她一走进门，奈娅西亚就转过身来。她刚好够高，能从门上的窗户底部角落往外看。她微笑着挥手向妈妈告别。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Oh, her little face in the window, waving.
哦，她在窗户里的小脸，挥着手。
Other parents also follow the new rules, and drop-off goes without a hitch.
其他家长也遵守新规则，接送进行得非常顺利。
The kids settle into their classrooms pretty quickly. All that planning is paying off. Mr. McGuire and I speed walk through the school, and we see kids patiently waiting to use the bathroom, where they're only allowed to use every other stall to maintain space.
孩子们很快就在教室里安顿下来了。所有的计划都得到了回报。麦奎尔先生和我快速走过学校，我们看到孩子们耐心地等着使用洗手间，在那里他们只被允许使用每隔一个隔间以保持空间。
We're figuring that out for tomorrow.
我们明天会解决这个问题。
He points out a sixth grade class reading The Outsiders at their desks that have shields set up on them, like little cubicles. The kids don't even fuss that much about wearing their masks.
他指出了一个六年级班级正在他们的课桌上读《局外人》，桌子上设置了盾牌，像是小隔间。孩子们甚至没为了戴口罩而大惊小怪。
When I sat down to the bright sunlight from the darkness of the movie house--
当我坐在从电影院黑暗中投射出的明亮阳光下时——
It seems like a smooth start to being back in school, except for one thing. As we pass by a second grade classroom, we both notice that there's only a single kid in it. Mr. McGuire kind of breezes by, continuing to walk and point out other classrooms. But I stop and make him come back. The second grader is sitting in the middle of the room, looking lonely and small behind rows of cubicle desks.
看起来回到学校有个顺利的开始，除了这件事。当我们经过一个二年级教室时，我们都注意到里面只有一个孩子。麦奎尔先生轻快地走过，继续走着并指出其他教室。但我停下来让他回来。那个二年级学生坐在房间中间，在隔间桌后面看起来孤独而瘦小。
Just one?
只有一个？
Huh? Two first graders-- these two are first graders.
嗯？两个一年级——这两个是一年级。
Oh. No, but she's just got one second grader?
哦。不，但她只有一个二年级学生？
Yeah, second grader. Yeah, so, again, that--
是的，二年级学生。是的，所以，再说一次，那个——
We continue down the hall. Other classrooms also have way too many empty desks. On the first day back, a lot of kids are missing.
我们继续沿着走廊走。其他教室也有太多的空座位。开学第一天，很多孩子都不见了。
226 kids were supposed to show up for school today. Another 45 signed up to stay virtual. Just after 9:00 AM, David and the two assistant principals get the actual attendance number from the school counselor in the hallway.
226个孩子本应今天出现在学校。另有45人报名留在虚拟课堂。刚过早上9点，大卫和两位副校长从走廊里的学校顾问那里得到了实际的出勤人数。
How many?
多少人？
102, not including the three that's online so far.
102个，不包括到目前为止在线上的三个。
Which makes 105 students out of 226. Just three days before this on Friday, most of those students were in class virtually. Now over a hundred of them had disappeared. Mr. McGuire talked to one of his assistant principals about what happened.
也就是226名学生中有105名。就在三天前的周五，大多数学生还在虚拟上课。现在有一百多人消失了。麦奎尔先生和他的副校长谈到了发生了什么。
I said, did we miss something this summer? She said, what do you mean? I said, did we miss something? Why are there so many kids missing? And she was like, I don't know. We got to find them. We just got to find out. And I was just like, yeah.
我说，我们这个夏天错过了什么吗？她说，你是什么意思？我说，我们错过了什么吗？为什么有这么多孩子不见了？她就像，我不知道。我们得找到他们。我们只需要找出来。我就像，是的。
But I said, we communicated, right? We had it on the website. We put it on our social media. We sent ClassDojo. We used the parablast, right? We did mailers. We did those things, right?
但我说，我们沟通了，对吧？我们在网站上有它。我们在社交媒体上发布了。我们发送了ClassDojo。我们使用了集群广播，对吧？我们发了邮件。我们做了这些事，对吧？
Those things weren't enough. Mr. McGuire, the dean, the school counselor, the office manager, and a few teachers start calling parents, trying to figure out why their children didn't show up. I tried to figure it out too. I talked to several parents whose kids were not in school that first day, including Kierra Leonard. The reason she didn't take her kids in?
那些事情还不够。麦奎尔先生、院长、学校顾问、办公室经理和几位老师开始给家长打电话，试图弄清楚为什么他们的孩子没出现。我也试着找出原因。我采访了几个孩子第一天没在学校的家长，包括基拉·伦纳德。她没带孩子去学校的原因？
I just wanted to make sure that there were going to be no cases.
我只是想确保不会有病例。
Kierra actually really wanted to send her two children back to school. Things were getting kind of wild at home. Her seven-year-old daughter was sneaking out of bed and staying up all night.
基拉实际上真的很想让她的两个孩子回到学校。家里的情况有点失控了。她七岁的女儿会溜下床熬夜。
And she's up snacking and eating whatever she can find. She didn't go to sleep until the sun was coming up. She has a kitchen set in her room. I open the freezer, and there are the sprinkles to the cupcakes. What are you doing? Icing in the oven-- what are you doing?
她在吃零食，能找到什么就吃什么。直到太阳出来她才睡觉。她房间里有一套厨房设备。我打开冰箱，那是杯子蛋糕的糖屑。你在做什么？烤箱里的糖霜——你在做什么？
I couldn't wait. That's why I was so for them going to school, because it was just like the schedule was broke. It was like they were just doing whatever they wanted to do.
我等不及了。这就是为什么我这么支持他们去学校，因为就像日程表被打乱了。就像他们只是在做他们想做的任何事。
They needed to get back on a normal routine. At first, Kierra thought it seemed OK to send her kids to school. She went to a school orientation and thought the precautions seemed pretty sensible, like the desk shields and separate supplies for each student. But then--
他们需要回到正常的作息。起初，基拉觉得送孩子去学校似乎没问题。她参加了学校的说明会，认为预防措施看起来很合理，比如桌子上的挡板和每个学生分开的补给品。但然后——
After I went home from orientation, I went to get the kids from my mom. And that's when I explained to her what they had in place. And she just wasn't too sure about it, like, nuh-uh, not my grandbabies.
从说明会回家后，我去我妈那儿接孩子。就在那时，我向她解释了他们已经采取的措施。她不太确定，就像，不，不是我的孙辈。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I mean, she sits up and watches the news all day, so you can just imagine what's going through her head. And she's like, nuh-uh. Because she has to pick them up from school. They're with her after school. So, I mean, I couldn't argue with her not wanted to be playing Russian roulette with COVID. So that's when I started questioning it. And I was like, well, let's just see how it goes the first day, see if we hear anything.
我是说，她整天坐着看新闻，所以你可以想象她脑子里在想什么。她说，不。因为她得从学校接他们。放学后他们和她在一起。所以，我的意思是，我无法和不想玩新冠俄罗斯轮盘赌的她争论。所以就在那时我开始怀疑了。我就像，好吧，让我们看看第一天情况如何，看看我们是否听到什么。
So after the first two weeks of virtual learning, Kierra kept her kids at home instead of sending them into school for the first day back in person.
所以在两周的在线学习后，基拉让她的孩子留在家里，而不是在第一天送到学校进行线下上课。
I was torn. I knew they needed to be in class. It would help them more. But I wasn't sure if I wanted them to be with the first wave of kids that went back.
我很纠结。我知道他们需要去上课。那会更多地帮助他们。但我不太确定我是否想让他们成为第一波回去的孩子。
She thought they could keep doing virtual learning, but then they couldn't get into the online classroom. When the school called to check where the kids were, she explained why she didn't send them in. They reassured her that things were going well so far, and they asked if there was anything they could do to help get the kids into school.
她认为他们可以继续在线学习，但他们无法进入在线课堂。当学校打电话检查孩子在哪里时，她解释了她为什么没让他们去。他们向她保证到目前为止情况进展顺利，并询问有什么他们能帮忙让孩子去学校的。
When she told them it was hard to pick them up on Fridays, they said that was fine. They could keep the kids an extra half hour until their grandma got off work. This, plus the fact that there were no COVID cases those first few days, won over both Kierra and her mother.
当她告诉他们周五接孩子很难时，他们说那没关系。他们可以多留孩子半小时，直到她奶奶下班。这，加上头几天没有新冠病例的事实，赢得了基拉和她妈妈的支持。
And I guess she just seen how much they were willing to work with us. And she knows as well that they need to be in school.
我猜她只是看到了他们愿意与我们合作的程度。她也知道他们需要去学校。
The school was doing tons of calls like these, including to another mother, Jamela Williams, who also kept her son Tre home that first day. She had a lot of worries that would have seemed small, but suddenly seemed big.
学校进行了大量的此类通话，包括打给另一位母亲，贾梅拉·威廉姆斯，她第一天也让她的儿子特雷待在家里。她有很多担心，这些担心看起来很小，但突然似乎很大。
I spoke to more than one person. I spoke to three or four people, actually.
我不止和一个人谈过。我实际上和三四个人谈过。
So what were the types of things you wanted to know from them?
所以你想从他们那里了解什么类型的事情？
I wanted to know more about bathroom breaks, because I know they go in groups. And I know some kids don't wash their hands. I know my child sometimes doesn't wash his hands. So I was wondering, how would they take care of that sort of thing?
我想更多地了解洗手间休息，因为我知道他们成群结队地去。而且我知道有些孩子不洗手。我知道我的孩子有时不洗手。所以我很好奇，他们会如何处理那种事？
And they told me that there would be frequent restroom breaks. The restrooms are cleaned. And I think it's after every section of kids go they thoroughly clean it. So that made me feel very good.
他们告诉我会有频繁的洗手间休息。洗手间会被清洁。而且我想是每批孩子去过之后他们都会彻底清洁。所以这让我感觉很好。
She also worried about her seven-year-old feeling comfortable and safe in a classroom with plastic shields on the desks and everyone in face masks.
她还担心她七岁的孩子在教室里感到舒服和安全，课桌上有塑料挡板，每个人都戴着口罩。
Well, I didn't want them to be scared. And they reassured me. And I've seen pictures, and it looked fine to me.
好吧，我不想让他们害怕。他们向我保证。我看过照片，对我来说看起来很好。
She was touched that so many people-- Tre's teacher, the school counselor, and Mr. McGuire-- were willing to talk through her concerns. Even the tone of their voices, that they were confident and jovial, signaled to her that they felt good about reopening. So maybe she didn't have as much to be worried about.
许多人愿意讨论她的担忧，这让她很感动——特雷的老师、学校顾问和麦奎尔先生。甚至他们声音的语调，他们既自信又愉快，向她发出信号，让他们对重新开放感觉良好。所以也许她没那么多可担心的。
It's a stunning amount of extra work for the school, convincing parents one by one for their kids to attend the school they're already enrolled in, but this is what it took in so many cases. By the end of that first week, the school tracked down all but three of the missing students. They convinced around 70 more kids to come in person, and another 40 or so decided to stay online. Jamela's son Tre went back to school that Tuesday. Kierra, the mom who had to convince her mother, she sent her kids on Thursday.
对于学校来说，这是一个令人震惊的额外工作量，一个一个地说服家长让他们的孩子去他们已经入学的学校，但在许多情况下这就是所需要的。第一周结束时，学校找到了除三个学生外的所有失踪学生。他们说服了另外70多个孩子亲自来，另有40多个决定留在网上。贾梅拉的儿子特雷周二回到学校。基拉，那个不得不说服她母亲的妈妈，她在周四送了她的孩子。
I just feel like you are having to make this decision that so many parents across the country are having to deal with right now.
我觉得你不得不做出这个决定，全国那么多的家长现在都得处理这个决定。
Yes. I was hoping that the other parents would make the decision for me so that I can ride their coattail, see how it was working for them and then see if it would work for us. So, I mean, if it has to be the other way around, so be it. Everything's fine-- no cases, no sick children, no problems-- but still just week two, week one for us.
是的。我本希望其他家长能替我做出决定，这样我就能骑在他们的尾巴上，看看这对他们是否有用，然后看看它是否对我们有用。所以，我的意思是，如果非得反过来，那就这样吧。一切都很好——没有病例，没有生病的孩子，没有问题——但这只是第二周，对我们来说是第一周。
This difficult decision of how kids should return to school in so many places has played out like this. The federal government left it to the states, the states left it to the schools, and the schools left it to the parents. And how are the parents supposed to know what the right answer is to any of this? No wonder it played out the way it did at Tindley.
孩子们应该如何回归学校的这个艰难决定在许多地方就是这样上演的。联邦政府把它留给了州，州留给了学校，学校留给了家长。家长怎么可能知道这一切的正确答案是什么呢？难怪廷德利的情况就是这样发展的。
Stephanie Wang, she's the bureau chief of Chalk Beat Indiana. To read their education coverage from around the country, go to chalkbeat.org.
斯蒂芬妮·王，她是Chalk Beat印第安纳州分社社长。要阅读他们来自全国各地的教育报道，请访问chalkbeat.org。
Act Five, The Leftovers. Of course, the big fear at every school right now is that they're going to start up classes in person in the fall and then the virus will arrive and spread through the student and teacher population, endangering everybody, and, of course, forcing them to shut down again, go back to mostly virtual learning. That happened at the University of North Carolina this month. Exactly one week after classes began, with 177 confirmed cases at the time, the school ended in-person undergraduate instruction and told students to start moving out of the residence halls and go home.
第五幕，剩下的部分。当然，每所学校现在最大的恐惧是他们会在秋天开始线下课程，然后病毒会进入并在学生和教师群体中传播，危及所有人，当然，迫使他们再次关闭，回到主要是虚拟学习的状态。本月北卡罗来纳大学就发生了这种情况。在上课整整一周后，当时有177例确诊病例，学校终止了线下本科教学，并告诉学生开始搬出宿舍回家。
Kids have taken a while to clear out. And as they have, clusters of coronavirus cases keep popping up around campus in dorms, and fraternities, and a sorority house. NPR staffers Lauren Migaki and Elissa Nadworny were on UNC's campus last Saturday and happened to be at the school paper, The Daily Tar Heel, when one of the paper's editors, Brandon Standley, got a text about the latest cluster, the school's eighth at that point, before the school announced it. It was in the dorm called Craige.
孩子们花了一段时间才搬出去。随着他们搬出，校园宿舍、兄弟会和女生联谊会中不断出现冠状病毒病例聚集。美国全国公共电台的工作人员劳伦·米加基和埃丽莎·纳德沃尼上周六在北卡大学校园里，碰巧在该校报纸《每日焦油后跟》报社，当时报社编辑之一布兰登·斯坦利收到了一条关于最新聚集病例的短信，那是学校宣布之前。它在名为克雷格的宿舍里。
Oh, man. Craige just reported that it's about to have a cluster. So we got notification from a housing employee. I think that's all the high-rises and most of the first-year residence halls.
天哪。克雷格刚刚报告说它要出现一个聚集性病例了。所以我们收到了住房员工的通知。我想那是所有高层建筑和大多数一年级宿舍。
And Craige is where you live.
而克雷格是你住的地方。
Craige is where I live. So that's really not exciting to know via a text message. This is not good.
克雷格是我住的地方。所以通过短信得知这一点真的不令人兴奋。这可不好。
That was this past Saturday. One of our producers Robyn Semien called Brandon four days later to see what happened.
那是上周六。我们的一位制作人罗宾·塞米恩四天后打电话给布兰登，看看发生了什么。
After Brandon heard his dorm, Craige, had a cluster, his mom called, who wanted him to leave school. He said, no, Mom. Then he and some of his friends started texting on a group chat.
在布兰登听说他的宿舍克雷格出现聚集性病例后，他妈妈打电话，想让他离开学校。他说，不，妈妈。然后他和一些朋友开始在群聊里发短信。
One of my coworkers said "what" in all caps. One of them said [BLEEP] me. One of them said, what if we've come into contact with those people? And they're going home and would potentially spread it to their communities.
我的一位同事用大写字母说了“什么”。一位同事说[哔哔]我。一位同事说，如果我们和那些人有过接触怎么办？他们回家可能会把病毒传播给他们的社区。
One of them called us cluster Craige. One of them was scared about getting tested. So she said, if you see me having a panic attack getting tested, no, you didn't. I talked about how I was scared to get the COVID test too. I said, if you see me crying because that COVID test poked my brain, no, you didn't.
一位同事叫我们“聚集克雷格”。一位同事担心检测。所以她说，如果你看到我因为检测而恐慌，不，你没看到。我也谈到了我害怕接受新冠检测的事。我说，如果你看到我因为新冠检测戳我的大脑而哭，不，你没看到。
Ultimately, in the evening, he went back to his dorm.
最终，那天晚上，他回到了他的宿舍。
And the parking lot outside the building was just completely full. And there was families moving out. There were students moving all their stuff. It was a lot of people in one tiny, little area.
大楼外的停车场简直挤满了。有家庭在搬出去。有学生在搬走他们所有的东西。在一个狭小的区域里有很多人。
And they were walking up and down the breezeway with fridges, and boxes, and things like that. And I had to walk straight into that, because it's really the clearest entrance to get to the building. So I had to walk straight through that and straight into the main area where people were taking the elevators up and down.
他们提着冰箱、箱子之类的东西在走廊里走来走去。我不得不直接走进那个，因为它真的去大楼最清晰的入口。所以我不得不直接穿过那个，直接进入人们上下电梯的主要区域。
It sounds pretty crowded.
听起来很拥挤。
I would say it was. I felt nervous.
我会说确实如此。我感到紧张。
He beelined to his room on the third floor, talked to nobody. By Sunday, all four of his suitemates had left. Brandon does not want to leave. UNC has said basically, we know we invited you back, but please leave.
他直奔三楼他的房间，和任何人没说话。到周日，他的所有四个室友都走了。布兰登不想离开。北卡大学基本上说，我们知道我们邀请你回来，但请离开。
Brandon is technically allowed to stay. He's paid to manage the dorm RAs, resident assistants, who clearly have fewer and fewer residents to assist. Brandon has a bathroom to himself now. It's kind of nice.
布兰登在技术上是被允许留下的。他被支付报酬来管理宿舍RA，宿舍助理，他们显然有越来越少的居民可以协助。布兰登现在有一个属于他自己的洗手间。这还挺好的。
Yeah, I'm hoping to stay, and I'm hoping to keep my job because this is my livelihood right now. This is how I make ends meet. This is how I put gas in my car and how I feed myself. And I'm really hoping that that doesn't disappear.
是的，我希望能留下，我希望能保住我的工作，因为这是我现在的生计。我就是这样维持收支平衡的。我就是这样给车加汽油以及养活自己的。我真的希望那不会消失。
As of now, Brandon and the 15 remaining RAs can stay, but he sees the problem. If the resident count gets too low, the university will terminate them and kick them out.
到目前为止，布兰登和剩下的15名RA可以留下，但他看到了问题。如果居民人数过低，大学就会终止他们并将他们踢出去。
So Craige, a big, fairly empty dorm meant for about 650 people, a six-story building shaped like an X with an A, B, C, and D wing, lounges, and an elevator tower in the center, Brandon estimated on Wednesday there may be 90 residents left. I talked to Brandon in his dorm room. At a certain point, I ask him to please just walk into the hall for me.
所以克雷格，一个大而相当空旷的宿舍，本意是为了容纳大约650人，一个X形的六层建筑，带有A、B、C和D翼、休息室和中央电梯塔，布兰登周三估计可能还剩下90名居民。我在布兰登的宿舍房间里采访了他。在某个时候，我请他为我走进走廊。
Give me one second.
给我一秒钟。
OK. I'm so curious if there's people out there.
好的。我很好奇外面有没有人。
Yeah. Let me put on some shoes.
是的。让我穿上鞋子。
And a mask.
还有口罩。
And a mask. All right. Here we go.
还有口罩。好的。我们开始吧。
He leaves his room on the third floor.
他离开了他三楼的房间。
[DOOR SHUTTING]
[门关闭声]
All the hallways are outdoors, breezeways.
所有的走廊都在户外，有廊道。
But looking out, I can see up to the sixth floor and down to the ground. There's literally nobody in the breezeway, not a single person on the volleyball court. I thought I just heard a door open, but maybe I'm crazy.
但往外看，我可以看到六楼和地面。廊道里简直没人，排球场上甚至没一个人。我以为我刚才听到门开了，但也许我疯了。
What about the lounge? Are you close to the lounge?
休息室呢？你离休息室近吗？
Yeah. Let me go to the lounge.
是的。让我去休息室。
OK, let's go see.
好的，我们去看看。
Nobody. It sounds so quiet.
没人。它听起来太安静了。
It is quiet there. The light is on. There is not a single person here. I'm walking into the basketball side now.
那里很安静。灯亮着。这里甚至没一个人。我现在正走向篮球场那边。
OK.
好的。
Oh, there's a person.
哦，有一个人。
Oh.
哦。
There's actually a person.
确实有一个人。
A student who was late and can't talk, one student.
一个迟到不能谈话的学生，一个学生。
I'm looking out now at the basketball side, doing the same thing that I was doing on the volleyball side. And I can see up to the sixth floor and down to the ground. And there's not a single person. Doesn't even look like the light is on in any of the rooms. And there's kind of just nobody.
我现在往篮球场那边看，做着我在排球场那边做的同样的事。我可以从六楼看到地面。甚至没一个人。看起来房间里的灯甚至没亮。而且有点只是没人。
He goes to the kitchen-- nobody. Does the entire fourth floor, too. Nobody.
他去了厨房——没人。整个四楼也一样。没人。
In August, just before the school went online, The Daily Tar Heel ran a piece with the frustrated headline, "We All Saw This Coming." But not Brandon. He wasn't as skeptical of UNC's reopening plan.
八月，就在学校上线之前，《每日焦油后跟》刊登了一篇标题沮丧的文章，“我们都预见到了这一点。”但布兰登没有。他没有那么怀疑北卡大学的重开计划。
And I thought that if there was an outbreak on campus that the university would lock down the buildings, lock down the campus, force everyone to quarantine. It's kind of like a snowstorm. I just thought it was going to be just like that. It was going to be like two weeks worth of a snow day for everybody. And we were all going to be sick, and it was going to suck, but it was going to be OK enough, you know what I mean?
我以为如果在校园里有爆发，大学会封锁大楼，封锁校园，强迫每个人隔离。这有点像暴风雪。我只是认为它会像那样。对每个人来说，这就像两周的雪天。我们都会生病，这会很糟糕，但这会好起来的，你知道我的意思吗？
You really had confidence in their plan.
你真的对他们的计划有信心。
I did.
我有的。
Two weeks of quarantine, that was Brandon's backup plan for the university. The university had no such backup plan for Brandon.
两周的隔离，那是布兰登对大学的备用计划。大学对布兰登根本没这样的备用计划。
They don't. I was stunned. I was shocked. I was like, are you serious? What was the point of touting the safety plans that you had in place if you had any sort of inkling that if there's an outbreak that you're going to send people home? I would love to be in the room where that happened and sit down and listen to them say, well, if there's 300 cases, we're just going to send everybody home. Because that's what they ended up doing, is there was a little over 300 cases reported within a week and a half, two weeks, and they sent everyone home.
他们没有。我惊呆了。我被震惊了。我就像，你是认真的吗？如果你有任何一点暗示，如果爆发了你要把人送回家，你炫耀你到位的安全计划有什么意义？我很想在那个地方的房间里坐下来听他们说，好吧，如果有300个案例，我们就把每个人送回家。因为那正是他们最后做的，在一周半、两周内报告了300多例，他们就把每个人送回家了。
UNC did a survey over the summer, asking students if they'd go to parties this year. Over a quarter said yes. Maybe that's the only thing the university needed to know.
北卡大学夏天做了一项调查，询问学生今年是否会去参加派对。超过四分之一的人说会。也许那是大学唯一需要知道的事情。
Robyn Semien is one of the producers of our show.
罗宾·塞米恩是节目的制作人之一。
Our program was produced today by Emanuele Berry and Diane Wu. The people put together today's show include Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Dana Chivvis, Aviva DeKornfeld, Noor Gill, Damien Graef, Michelle Harris, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Mae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Executive editor is David Kestenbaum.
我们今天的节目由埃马努埃莱·贝里和黛安·吴制作。今天节目的人员包括比姆·阿德温米、埃尔娜·贝克、达纳·奇维斯、阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德、努尔·吉尔、达米安·格雷夫、米歇尔·哈里斯、塞斯·林德、米基·米克、莉娜·米西齐斯、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·梅·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、罗宾·塞米恩、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和朱莉·惠特克。我们的管理编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜勒拉赫曼。执行编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。
Special thanks today to Cheryl Cofie, Ricky Allman, Andrea Mitchell, Sally Goza, Peggy Fletcher Stack, Patrick Wall, Joicki Floyd, Lisa Pollak, Vincent Kolb-Lugo, John Rabe, Karen Soto, Carrie and George Frieswyk, Lisa Nhan, Doyin Oyeniyi, Andy Kenney, America Billy, Elizabeth Friary, WFYI in Indianapolis. And thanks to the many, many students, parents, and educators we called as we put together today's show.
今天特别感谢谢丽尔·科菲、里基·奥尔曼、安德里亚·米切尔、莎莉·戈扎、佩吉·弗莱彻·斯塔克、帕特里克·沃尔、乔伊基·弗洛伊德、丽莎·波拉克、文森特·科尔布-卢戈、约翰·拉贝、凯伦·索托、卡丽和乔治·弗里斯维克、丽莎·南、多音·奥耶尼伊、安迪·肯尼、美国比利、伊丽莎白·弗里亚里、印第安纳波利斯的WFYI。感谢我们在制作今天节目时联系到的许多学生、家长和教育工作者。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to any of our over 700 programs for absolutely free.
《美国生活》由公共广播交流中心PRX提供给公共广播电台。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们超过700个节目中的任何一个。
Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he has really been cracking himself up all this week with this prank he came up with. Every single time I sit down in the studio to record anything, he swings the door open and yells--
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他这周一直因为他想出的这个恶作剧而乐得不行。每次我坐进演播室准备录音时，他就会猛地打开门大喊——
Hey! Sh.
嘿！嘘。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。